hello there i'm alana welcome to my
channel and if you don't know me i am an
australian but i've been living in the
us for the last seven years almost seven
it would be seven in january and i
realized when i first moved to the us i
made loads of like comparison videos
between australia and the us they are
pretty different countries to live in
culturally
but i've never made one about
thanksgiving um so this video is more
directed at my australian audience than
it is at um my us audience though it is
worth noting and i only found this out
like yesterday that um
a lot of americans don't know that
thanksgiving is not globally celebrated
uh
there are different versions of
thanksgiving that different countries do
have
um
but they're not on the same day and
they're not the same thing like i know
canada has one that is very specifically
about like giving thanks for
harvest which has been around for a
really long time but theirs is in
october and there is an unsavory history
around the american version of
thanksgiving but i don't feel like the
person to tell you that what i am going
to do today is give you my top five ish
things that i
think perceive or noticed about american
thanksgiving again we do not have
thanksgiving in australia i've had a
pretty
traditional thanksgiving because my
ex-boyfriend
is american he lives in texas um was
born in oklahoma
that is like very
in my opinion um
sort of
stereotypical classic
american family kind of vibes where they
have you know southern accents and they
get together and they do thanksgiving
um but i have also done what most people
do which is called friendsgiving uh
which is really just you like go to a
friend's house which is what i'm doing
this afternoon and everybody brings food
i did one on sunday where they had a
potluck where everybody brought some
some different kinds of food and you
just kind of hang out and eat together
which makes sense if you go with the
version of it that is um more
specifically about being thankful for
harvest and farmers and all that stuff
even though it seems like it's deviated
from that a little bit uh so
thanksgiving the way that i celebrated
it in texas is actually really similar
to the way that australians do
christmas
and christmas in america
is underwhelming to me as a result
because these two days are so close by
um the fact that they're literally a
month apart on this occasion it's
november 25th december is sorry
christmas is december 25th literally 30
days apart um means that people kind of
don't necessarily want to do the same
thing twice in a row um and yeah of
course
everything i'm saying here is just from
my experiences other people have totally
different ones i'm not trying to tell
you this is the only way to do it it's
just how i've experienced it over the
last seven years
as a foreigner so yeah there's
friendsgiving which is you know friends
get together and just eat generally um
but the family traditional thanksgiving
it destroys any of the cities that i've
lived in traffic gets so bad because so
many people have to fly out i've lived
in san jose san francisco and la
and uh
the days before thanksgiving are
terrible like the roads are just
destroyed like nothing i've ever seen
worse than christmas it's awful because
it's such a family specific
holiday that everything just gets
terrible um that's the first impression
that i have is like okay around
thanksgiving everybody leaves to go see
their families i don't do that because i
don't have family in the us all my
family's in australia so i don't partake
in that i just know the roads are going
to go to [ __ ] um
similar to christmas or the shopping
centres or malls as they call them here
are full loads of people hard to get a
park people are just buying food
generally thanksgiving day itself
i've had it two ways
people will do lunch or dinner um well
yeah the turkey is the most common thing
that everybody knows of there's this
thing with cranberry sauce i don't even
know how that became a go-to um i
couldn't tell you but cranberry sauce
is a real thing it's like cranberry
jelly kind of
um like a jam which we would call it in
australia it's also thanksgiving is the
first time that i ever had a biscuit in
australia if you're one of the americans
watching
a biscuit is um
a cookie in
australia that's not really a one-to-one
because we still have cookies cookies
are like chocolate chip cookies i don't
know how to even just find i know what a
biscuit is um but a biscuit in the u.s
is kind of like a doughy wet
buttery
scone it's
the first time that i heard of one was a
friend was drunk and i was driving and
we went through a mcdonald's
drive-through together and he asked for
sausage and biscuit and i was disgusted
because i thought he was asking for like
a biscuit like a cookie
with sausage i was horrified until i saw
what it was
um biscuits are delicious
let me see if i can pull up a picture
because biscuits are not
i don't think we have an equivalent in
australia at all um biscuit thanksgiving
it really does just look like a scone
there
this thing
oh i've not seen that before turkey
stuffed biscuits
wow that's elaborate yeah you can kind
of make them like in a little sandwiches
they it's just
this looks really dry but you can kind
of see the butter on it this is all
buttery
and they they kind of melt in your mouth
um the way that we had them home made
when i was in texas
was with gravy which i think is a pretty
common way
to have
biscuits it's an interesting thing i'm
sure i'm sure this sounds weird to any
of the americans i've seen that where
you can get biscuits that have like
other things in them that's that looks
like they've just been sprinkled with
herbs but
you can get them with stuff in them um
this is kind of the idea
it's a very see that's
that's the kind of biscuits i'm talking
about
like if i put in maybe australian
biscuit
you'd get
biscuits these are all biscuits i don't
know that i tim tam is a biscuit it is
these this is what i mean by biscuit
it's like i know what it is but i don't
know how to describe how i know what it
is
definitely a biscuit those are anzac
that's like one of our most famous
um
types of biscuits served in australia
that's why it's coming up so repeatedly
as an anzac biscuit but yeah a pie is
another thing that's really common
pumpkin pie
apple pie that is probably a staple some
people make pies but a lot of people
just buy them
pumpkin pie i think is the most common
one
and the turkey is just like kind of
becomes a mascot um around the period of
time as well where people like break the
wishbone for for the turkey and all that
stuff so i think that's most of the
staple food covered at least that i have
seen is this also just salads and mac
and cheese is really common but
decorations are also a huge thing
obviously the pumpkins thing around fall
kia is really specific to where you know
around autumn people start bringing out
pumpkins and orange leaves and i don't
feel like that really happens in
australia either maybe it is now i feel
like globalization is on the rise and
people from
other countries are adopting american um
customs more readily like certainly
halloween has gotten more and more
popular in australia over time when i
was a kid i'd never even been
trick-or-treating never once i had never
been trick-or-treating nor have i ever
had a trick-or-treater come to my house
um just because
it's it wasn't when i was a kid 20 years
ago a thing that was done in australia
it was really um something we saw as
being american-centric though of course
halloween
goes further than that
um
but yeah like the pumpkin decorating
stuff is not really something that we do
i feel like australia because of the
timing of where thanksgiving would be
australia just kind of transitions
straight into christmas
in november it's christmas all of the
shopping centers again malls as the
americans call them uh decorated with
christmas decorations
way earlier because it seems like an
unwritten rule here that you only put
your christmas decorations up after
thanksgiving is done
um
which
just means that like november feels like
a really different kind of period of
time here which i kind of like it's like
this is what october and november are
you go straight from everything spooky
to everything's pumpkins to everything's
christmas and it's it's the distinction
is really nice and it's something that i
think is
um very fun about living in america is
just like
everything is such a uh like a theme
park show kind of which is which is
really fun so if you've got your food
which is the main thing and specific
kinds of food and then you've got all
your decorations um there are specific
things that people do other than just
hang out and eat on thanksgiving
sometimes too there is the macy's
thanksgiving day parade that's
definitely a thing that people watch a
parade they make these like thanksgiving
centerpieces the tables are all laid out
with like flowers and they're all
very pretty and and warm earthy stuff um
and and one part of it is yeah
definitely american football is a big
thing on thanksgiving they watch they
watch uh
gridiron as we call it in australia
and part of it is supposed to say
something that you're thankful for which
is also part of it that i really like
that i think is actually very nice yeah
just saying something that you're
thankful for i think that like
especially religious families probably
tend to do that um but i've seen you
know the friendsgiving thing people do
that too where you just go around in a
circle and say something that you're
thankful for again very american thing
to do australians would would think that
that was
terrible i think even the brits would be
like oh
i'm not doing that like something that
is against our nature
um will you just go around in a circle
and say what you're thankful for um i
did one time have friends try to trick
me into thinking you had to give gifts
when i first moved and i didn't know any
better but you don't and yeah the staple
is like having leftovers for days
afterwards again
very very very similar to uh
to christmas yeah there are scavenger
hunts sometimes i guess for kids game
nights is a thing
movies yeah it's all it's all just like
nice cozy
wintry stuff where you are kicking off
the holiday season which again is a
really nice thing about it and people
try to take time to reflect on the year
i've definitely seen movie marathons
where there are
thanksgiving movies
uh instead of christmas movies um one
thing that i guess i can add is a final
note that's not directly related but
something australia does that
america doesn't do
kind of instead of thanksgiving is
easter easter
in america basically doesn't exist um
not compared to australia at least
easter is so small here you get more
days off in australia for easter more
days off work
and
every all the stores in australia all
your kmarts and your targets and your
myers and your david jones i don't think
most of those exist
here uh i think kmart used to but shut
down um does still exist in australia
still going hard
they like get fully decorated for easter
there's chocolate everywhere there are
giant easter bunnies um america you
could go around and like you wouldn't
even know it was easter like there are
some but
not in comparison to australia at all
like not even close um of any of the
cities that i've been to around that
time of year it pales in comparison
which is so surprising to me because
america is uh the us i keep i keep
saying america by default sorry about
that
the us is
more religious than australia is um
on the whole so it always seems very
surprising to me but yeah overall i do
really like it it is fun but it's
obviously not something i partake in it
has no family significance to me it's
not something where i feel like you know
oh i wish i was with my family because
it's just not something that my family
celebrates or has ever celebrated they
don't text me and wish me happy
thanksgiving you know
i think that's most of it it's it's
pretty simple overall yeah i don't know
here's whatever this video is how fun
somebody finds it interesting i hope all
of my american friends are having a
lovely thanksgiving
and um all my australians
hopefully i'll be home for christmas
hopefully we'll see
that would be great
no turkey mostly just a lot of prawns
but yeah that's pretty much it just
wanted to chat about it let me know if
there's anything that i missed or
anything that i should try
i'm down to to definitely try it out and
i will see you guys next time bye